منعطف جديد هو الاخطر في الاحتجاجات مقتل
ضابط اردني برتبه عقيد في الامن العامه
احداث شغب تلتها اجواء هادئه لا تعني
انتهاء الاحتجاجات التي تشدد السلطات على
احقيه مطالبها طالما بقيت بعيدا عن العنف
هنا جنوب العاصمه عمان تحديدا منطقه
الحسينيه التي شهدت كباقي مناطق الاردن
احتجاجات شعبيه على ارتفاع اسعار المشتقات
النفطيه توحدت المطالب واختلف المشهد بعد
اعمال شغب انتهت بمقتل الضابط الاردني
العقيد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح العاهل
الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني قدم واجب
العزاء لعشيره الدلابيح مؤكدا على انفاذ
القانون والتعامل بحزم امام كل من يرفع
سلاح بوجه الدوله
اليوم ليس كبارح
اطلب من جميع المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل
الاماكن التي تضم اعمال العنف
فصل الاحتجاجات السلميه
المسموحه والتعبير السلمي عن اعمال العنف
تستمر المطالب اليوم بوتيره هادئه وسط
اضراب مستمر للشاحنات نفذ منذ 10 ايام
حكومه متقله بالمطالب اهمها اليوم تخفيض
اسعار المشتقات النفطيه من جهه ومواطنون
غاضبوننا حمل الحكومه مسئوليه التاجيج من
جهه اخرى
اطلب واحد ينزلوا ام المحروقات
لم تدير ازمه ولا كانه فيها ازمه تعنيها
الازمه الحكومه بعيده كل البعد عن الازمه
هذا الحكي احنا مش مقبول احنا ابناء وطن
وغيرتنا على وطننا كبيره وهاي بلدنا
نحميها بدمنا وبروحنا وكلنا فداء الوطن بس
مش انه توقف الحكومه عز انك تسولف مع
المواطنين او تحكي مع المواطنين وما بين
عدم استطاعه المواطن تحمل المزيد من
الضغوط الاقتصاديه وتاكيد الحكومه عدم
قدرتها على دعم المحروقات يؤكد طرفها
المعادله رفضهما اعمال العنف والتخريب
بعيدا عن عدم الوصول الى نقطه لقاء تنهي
ازمه البلاد الاقتصاديه من مدينه الحسينيه
جنوب العاصمه عمان عماد العضايله العربيه